y comenzó el enfrentamiento de twitter
con y la más que en el que la junta
directiva de la red social está tratando
de resolver meses de incertidumbre sobre
esta compra que planteó el
multimillonario por nada menos que 44
mil millones de dólares más que entonces
busca romper este acuerdo argumentando
que no ha tenido suficiente información
sobre la cantidad de cuentas spam
cuentas falsas digamos en esta red
social que según él son críticas para el
valor de esta empresa un tribunal de
delaware va a resolver este asunto y por
supuesto está aquí con nosotros en
estudio daniela blandón para
desenmarañar toda esta novela financiera
digamos porque no es política aunque
tendrá algo de política también pero
vamos a desde mañana esta novela
financiera dani bienvenida hola raúl muy
buenos días feliz viernes para usted una
novela que como me entró en el final y
que no va a tener final feliz como todas
las novelas a las que estamos
acostumbrados así es y pues mire este es
un tribunal pequeño pero muy importante
porque es el que lleva a todas las
grandes peleas entre corporaciones y
cuya juez principal
ella se llama katelyn mccormick ya le
dio una pequeña victoria a twitter y es
quien en ilo nos quería llevar todo este
asunto de la demanda a juicio en febrero
de 2023 para tener tiempo de resolver
este asunto tan espinoso pero la juez
twitter decía que fuera en septiembre de
este año y la juez decidió que será para
octubre que va a durar cinco días danny
las claves de esta mega demanda mire la
demanda fue instaurada el 12 de julio
apenas cuatro días después de que y los
que decidiera que no que él ya no va a
comprar twitter y tiene 62 páginas nos
pusimos a mirar en todas esas 62 páginas
con declaraciones explosivas de twitter
hacia ahí lo en bosque entre ellas que
primero la oferta de compra vino
acompañada de amenazas desde un
principio y es que los moscos
supuestamente les habría dicho que si no
le vendían la compañía dell iba a salir
de todas sus acciones y tienen 10% casi
un 96 por ciento hoy de la compañía
también que actúa de manera hipócrita y
lo hizo de mala fe también qué
el proceso no es para él más que una
broma elaborada y algo bien grave y es
que hay temores sobre el uso que le dará
a la información suministrada por
twitter y es que twitter durante todo
este tiempo le ha venido dando
información a él o en moscú sobre su
operación información que ni siquiera
estaba obligado a hacerlo por el acuerdo
que firmaron y sin embargo se la
entregaron pero ellos dicen el gen desde
un principio nos dijo que una de sus
tres opciones era montar digamos un
nuevo negocio o en un competidor para
twitter así que puede estar utilizando
esta información claro e información
clasificada digamos para esta red social
pero es que precisamente daniela twitter
acaba publicar sus estados financieros
como está la compañía no muy bien dentro
luego de que se retirara y lo más y
decir ya no lo quiero comprar la
compañía claro el principal golpe que ha
recibido la compañía es a través de sus
accionistas la acción ha venido cayendo
costaba 44 mil millones de dólares o ese
era el precio que estaba ofertando y lo
en mosca ahora vale menos de 30 mil
millones de dólares
como ustedes lo dicen salieron ya los
resultados financieros del segundo
trimestre de este año que reflejan
entonces ingresos por mil 180 millones
de dólares menos un 1% menos que hace un
año pero también menos de lo que
esperaba el mercado financiero tiene
adicionalmente pérdidas por 270 millones
de dólares que no son comparables porque
el año pasado había tenido unas pequeñas
ganancias y activos usuarios diarios 237
8 millones esto es un 16.6 por ciento
más que el año pasado las claves de
estos estados financieros es que primero
twitter emitió un comunicado bastante
corto no es lo que está acostumbrado y
dice que la culpa de la pérdida de
ingresos y de lo que ha pasado con la
acción es del acuerdo con y los moscos
que no se ha podido concretar también
dice que no habrá teleconferencia ni
comunicado a los accionistas y mucho
menos proyecciones a futuro hasta que
este acuerdo pues no se resuelva y lo
tercero es que esta mala racha no
solamente es de 'twitter' la mala racha
de todas las empresas de redes sociales
de hecho el jueves se perdieron más de
80 mil millones de dólares en
capitalización bursátil o sea en valor
de las empresas en bolsa de las
compañías de redes sociales después de
que snap chat revelará unos resultados
financieros que wall street' consideró
desastrosos entonces twitter facebook e
intereses de varias de ellas han perdido
valor en bolsa cómo se desarrollará
digamos este juicio sea realmente
twitter quiere que finalmente la
compramos o simplemente quiere que le
pague dinero por perder plata no quiere
que la compre porque si fuera un tema de
solamente la multa pues le cobrarían los
mil millones de dólares que tendría que
pagar irnos que por arrepentirse pero no
necesariamente lo llevarían a juicio lo
que ellos están pidiendo es que cierre
el negocio y es que les conviene porque
es un negocio que les daría mucho más
dinero de lo que vale la compañía en
este momento en bolsa nos odiamos pero
me compra la compañía pero vamos a
entonces ya saludar en este momento para
seguir desarrollando esta información
ana paula rumualdo ya sea directora del
área de tecnología digital en hogan
lovells mexico experta en privacidad de
regulación de inteligencia artificial es
otra guías digitales emergentes ana
paula gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 te saluda
revolvían que me acompaña nuestra
periodista económica daniela landon dan
hola ana paula muy buenos días y pues le
pregunto primero cómo va a terminar todo
este asunto y como también se compara
con otras grandes peleas de wall street
bueno pues esto parece que va a terminar
o la idea principal es que si termine en
la adquisición de twitter por parte de
hilo en moscú entonces aquí el principal
la principal preocupación es que la red
social pues prácticamente queda a la
deriva con alguien que parece que entró
en algo que fue para desviar a un
calentón de yo voy a arreglar esta red y
ya no tiene idea de cómo arreglar esa
red ya se dio cuenta que la forma que
propuso probablemente muy seguramente no
va a funcionar o probablemente nunca iba
a funcionar
entonces probablemente termine la
adquisición pero también aquí el
problema es que ya hay más la sangre
entre quién va a comprar y quiénes están
obligando a esta compra que ya ha pasado
en ocasiones anteriores
y finalmente termina en que se realice
esto a pesar de que exista pues pues una
mala disposición
de los dos lados pero ahora lo
importante es ver que en realidad de lo
que prometió cuando hizo el feeling ante
la sec de que iba a mejorar que te iba a
liberar el potencial de la red social a
ver si realmente eso pasa por lo pronto
esta especie de
perdón de huracán za el huracán en el
que entraron a partir de que se dio la
compra por 44 millones de dólares lo que
le ha traído a la compañía es únicamente
bajar su valor e interrumpir sus
operaciones
preocupaciones constantes por parte de
todos los empleados que no saben ni
están seguros para nada de que esto sea
la mejor decisión pero lo que sí saben
es que los accionistas quieren que se
venda porque no quieren perder plata
claro ana paula digamos que esto pudo
hacer digamos algún tipo de jugada por
parte de lomos para bajar el precio de
la compañía para bajar para comprarlo
por un menor valor muchísimo menos que
estos 44 mil millones ofrecidos
inicialmente
eso pudo ser una estrategia para comprar
pero yo creo que fue también una
estrategia más para ver mediático en
hilos que en realidad no puedo no no yo
creo que eso sería la tal vez de lo poco
que podríamos pensar que que hacen o
incluso dijo que para la próxima compra
bajo acá entonces no creo que con eso
esté pensando bajar las acciones de coca
simplemente es a veces va a dar unos
bandazos y lomos y que es justamente lo
que preocupa a la dirección de la
compañía si con esos mismos bandas o con
esa es la cultura como la que tiene
entes la la que pretende instaurar en
twitter aunque ya hayan bajado yo creo
que esto fue algo que
de alguna forma vino
bueno que está afectando pero no creo
que haya sido algo que tuviera en mente
sino desde el principio se te apreció
que el precio que le estaba ofreciendo
parecía que simplemente lo había
ofrecido porque 44 millones de dólares
no o sea es alto no
correspondía al valor que se esperaba
que podía tener esa compra entonces
también pues es el resultado de la misma
persona lidera de este magnate
ana paula raúl también recordar que este
magnate está en la mira de la comisión
de valores de eeuu por varias de sus
intervenciones en redes sociales no
solamente relacionadas con twitter sino
con tesla y con otras empresas que él
maneja ahora quiero preguntarle qué
tanta razón tiene y lo en moscú para
argumentar su retirada del negocio él
dice que no le están dando información
clara y precisa sobre las cuentas de
spam en que según la compañía
representan un 5 por ciento apenas del
total de cuentas activas esto puede ser
cierto o no
bueno primero nada más me gustaría
aclarar algo que sí ha tenido si estaba
en la mira de la cec porque por sus
tuits ha afectado el valor
el valor de las acciones pero esto no ha
sido porque él lo haya intentado haya
sido una estrategia sino que su forma
que se
también como de otros personajes que
parece que forma irreflexiva se
comunican a través del twitter terminó
afectando las acciones entonces por eso
le decían ya párale dejar estar
anunciando ese tipo de cosas que tienen
afectaciones o que pueden generar
afectaciones que parece que no las estás
teniendo en la mira y bueno pues
recordemos también que algunos tweets de
los modos incluso moyes han sido noticia
entonces eso terminaba afectando también
el valor de la compañía pero bueno
respecto al 5%
yo creo y bueno me parece y también
existen otros otros análisis que no es
que la compañía le esté mintiendo o sea
puede ser que sea ese que puede hacer
que sea más del 5% pero la realidad es
que las redes sociales lidian con un
montón de cuentas falsas hay informes de
transparencia de otras redes sociales
donde nos demuestran que del mundo de la
población mundial tienen el triple de
usuarios y que han borrado el doble de
eso o sea de cuentas falsas entonces
este es un problema muy serio y yo creo
que él
por lo que lo está diciendo ahorita y lo
hermoso es porque
él esperaba tener poder implementar de
una forma mucho más facilona la
metodología para la detección y
eliminación de cuentas que también desde
que lo anunció después de que joel
fácilmente ante la cec fue muy
cuestionado esto porque dijeron este no
es un problema tan sencillo como para
que se elimine la forma en la que lo
está proponiendo entonces yo creo que
más bien es que no le checa la
expectativa que tenía o la forma en la
que podía implementarlo con los
resultados que ha tenido ana paula le
habló entonces ya como una usuaria de
twitter
hay algo en todo esto que afecte o que
impliquen alguna implicación para los
usuarios en algún momento de toda esta
pelea
pues si en algún momento o más bien si
ocurre en lo que quieren los accionistas
que es la adquisición por parte de hilo
en moscú entonces habrá que ver de qué
forma se va a utilizar ahora se van a
utilizar ahora los datos obtenidos a
través de esta red social que
probablemente cambien no salió creo que
eso sería lo fundamental que
probablemente cambien las prácticas de
abuso y de analíticos de esta red social
fuera de que puede tener otro tipo de
implicaciones que tal vez se tendrían
que ver a otro nivel de cómo va a ser
la revisión de cuentas la bajada de
cuentas la apelación para de que eso
podría ser un poco más controlado por
otras por otras partes
administrativas
si puede haber un cambio significativo
en el uso de la información